welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's webinar use of gas
chromatography for the analysis of
cannabinoids and terpenoids isa PhD the
postdoctoral researcher at the
University of Texas at Arlington my name
is Judy O'Rourke and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by labyrinths
laggards is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop down box our speaker will
respond to your questions via email
following the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming dr. Luisa I will
now turn the presentation over to her
hello everybody and thank you very much
Judy for the introduction i'm allegra
and as mentioned earlier i'm gonna be
talking about the use of gas
chromatography for the analysis of
cannabinoids and therapies but before
actually getting into the research
itself i would like to give a small and
brief introduction about cannabis sativa
and its analysis about cannabinoids and
therapies and also about gas
chromatography so there can be a basic
knowledge of what I'm gonna be talking
about so as we can see from this little
diagram there are mainly six different
types of analytes that researchers want
to study in cannabis sativa can let me
know it said are the main components of
the plant and are the chemicals that
give the psycho activity and the medical
benefits
Turpin's that are actually not only
found in cannabis sativa but pretty much
in all types of plants and those are the
molecules that comfort pregnancies and
aromas and then we have four different
types of for other kinds of analytes
that they are called actually
contaminants so ideally they should not
be present they should not be present in
the plant and we have pesticides solvent
as news every metals and microbes and
toxins so as you can see after each name
of the analyte highlighted the different
methods that are most widely used for
the analysis of these analytes and we
can see how terpenes cannabinoids a some
pesticides and all solvent residues can
be analyzed by gas chromatography so
this is one of the main reasons why in
my opinion having this instrument in a
cannabis either research or even quality
control lab is extremely important so
gas chromatography as the name itself
says is the type of analytical method
that will analyze the old molecules in a
gas phase that means that the sample
does not actually have to be found in a
gas phase actually most of the time it's
either in a liquid or in a solid state
through headspace injection but what
means is that the injection port is such
high temperatures that all the all the
solvents and all the analytes are then
gonna be Malita are then gonna be
volatilized in the column itself so to
perform this type of analysis of course
we require analytes that have lower
boiling points and the separation itself
is actually based on the boiling or more
accurately the dew point and we can see
in here the chromatograph that we
obtained on the bottom left a
chromatograph that we obtained by
analyzing and differentiating Delta 9
THC and the it's two main metabolites
I'm not going to talk about this in
today's presentation but I just wanted
to give you an idea of how normals can
chromatogram in gas chromatography work
so as we mentioned
earlier gas chromatography is perfect
for the analysis of cannabinoids
terpenes or residual solvents and some
pesticides so cannabinoids are the main
components of cannabis sativa this plant
has been reported to have over a hundred
different species of them and because of
that and based on their structure and
their properties they have been divided
into ten different classes as we
mentioned that they come first
psychoactivity
especially Delta 9 THC that it's the
main psychoactive cannabinoid but also
the medical benefits and the importance
for the analysis of cannabinoids in
plant in the plant is not only for
potency potency is what we are actually
calling the level of Delta 9 THC but
also to understand the purity the
therapeutic effects that each different
strain can comfort but also trace
analysis trace analysis meaning for
instance whenever you're purchasing a
CBD oil you want to make sure that
allegedly there is no trace of any other
type of cannabinoids in the in the
extractive so we said that there are 10
different categories of cannabinoids but
for the purpose of this research we
solely put our effort in analyzing at
the eight different cannabinoids that
you can find at the bottom of the slide
of course we have Delta 9 THC because we
mentioned that is the most psychoactive
cannabinoid and it has always been the
cannabinoid of most interest then we
have its eyes O'Meara Delta 8 THC the
only difference between these two
molecules is the position of the double
bond between 8:00 9:00 to 9:00 10:00 and
we have Delta 9 THC a it's the acidic
component that is the precursor of Delta
9 THC this molecule is actually
extremely tricky to characterized by
GCMs because the carboxyl group that you
find on the phenyl group is highly label
at the temperatures of the GC injection
injector and therefore what happens to
this molecule is that it gets degraded
this carboxyl group gets kicked out and
so Delta 9 THC a is
to Delta 9 THC this will lead to both
are both negative because no Delta 9 THC
a will appear on the chromatogram but
also false positive because the amount
of Delta 9 THC is going to be detected
higher than what actually is found in
the plant so for this reason the
analysis of cannabinoids via GCMs
actually needs to be needs to be done
after a derivatives asian reaction
mainly silly Latian and this type of
reaction will actually protect the
carboxyl group avoiding it's the
carboxylation then therapies are the
second most important components of
cannabis sativa but as we mentioned
there they are found in any plant and in
nature there have been reported more
than 50,000 different types of terpenes
but cannabis sativa has been reported to
have so Lily 200 of them and they come
for holder and fragrances for instance
limonene is the terpene that is that
characterizes the lemon peel and
comforts that order
but some of them such as bethe Correia
filling have been reported to actually
have some therapeutic effects so as you
can see from the three bottom structures
of three different toppings their
chemical structure comforts them a
pretty high volatility so that you're
perfectly suitable for GC analysis and
as of today three different types of the
texture have been mainly used for the
analysis and the determination of
terpenes but all of them may have pros
and cons so for instance flame
ionization detector is excellent for
quantitative analysis but it's not so
reliable for the qualification of
terpenes because their distinction is
solely based on retention index indices
mass spectrometry at the same time at
this in the same way is great for
quantitative analysis but even in this
case the speciation between therapies is
done solely by comparison to standards
and the retention indices and then
finally there is this new fairly new
technique called the vacuum ultraviolet
detector it has been developed
2009 and it's good for quantitative
analysis but it's not as sensitive as
the other should a detector but it's
extremely reliable when used for
qualification because each molecule is
going to give a specific and unique
absorbance spectrum even when talking
and analyzing isomers that may be tricky
with the other two detectors so now I'm
actually going to start talking about
the project that we did throughout the
program so the first part is the
analysis of cannabinoids on GCMs so we
saw earlier what different types of an
why cannabinoids are important to be
studied and I mentioned the trace
analysis so this type of method will
actually give extremely low limits of
detection and for this reason this
method is not suitable for potency
testing but it's we have used data for
trace analysis and so to check whether
other components were found in CBD oils
or in other types of extracts so the
flights in these lights these two tables
only the only describe the different
types of conditions that I used the
table on the Left shows and describes
the affiliation reaction as we said
earlier the simulation agent that we
decided to use the SBS DFA that is
represented in the its molecular firm
structure is represented at the bottom
of the table and we use the one percent
of T MCS as the catalyst the procedure
is pretty fast and straightforward so
the the defender was Dryden of the
solvent with the knot with a stream of
nitrogen at 50 degrees and then 50 to 50
by volume of ethyl acetate and BST FA
plus the catalyst were added and
everything was incubated at 70 degrees
for 30 minutes this it's not extremely
necessary but we needed to speed up the
reaction and then before the injection
everything was cool down while on the
table on the right we actually see the
conditions used in the gas
chromatographer it's a pretty standard
separation we use the poli-sci lock same
column the polarity was not really high
as you can see it's only 5% if diphenyl
dimethyl and we use the split less
injection and we coupled it with the
shmatte drew triple quadrupole detector
so the triple quadrupole is as the name
says it's created by putting three
single quadruples in series 'm so all
the different ions that are formed in
the ionization source in this case
electro electron impact they are passed
through the three quadruples and
different modes can be used with that so
the mode that we used in this experiment
is called the multiple reaction
monitoring so I have a short animation
to explain that as you can see we have
on the left of the slide three different
balls with three different colors so in
real life these balls represent
different ions from the same molecule
that are formed in the ionization source
so once they are formed that these ions
will start passing through the first
quadrupole that actually works as a
filter so it will allow only one ion in
this case one ball to pass through the
second quadrupole the second quadrupole
it's not a filter but it just is a
fragmentation chamber so the ion that
was allowed to pass is going to be
further fragmented by a stream of argon
gas forming a different product and
smaller ions so in this case these
smaller balls and these smaller balls
are then going to pass through the third
quadrupole that is going to be working
as a filter just like the first one
allowing only one ion to pass and to
reach the detector so the the result is
that we get really high specificity and
high sensitivity compared to the other
modes in here I'm actually showing a two
chromatograms that we obtained with the
mrm mode the one on the top is the under
of a tithe cannabinoid so while the one
on the bottom is the simulator can
monoids so many differences already pop
up first of all of course the absence of
Delta 9 THC a in the and aromatized
chromatogram but we already explained
why then we can notice how the retention
time for each cannabinoid shifts whether
they are under baptised or if they are
sill elated for instance can na'vi know
that is number 7 when it's under river
Thais de so it's in its natural form
it's going to allude at around 19 point
75 minutes while once it's the rub it's
the rivet eyes it's going to allude at
seventeen point five and this is because
the solution not only protects the
carboxyl group but also lowers the
boiling point and the the last
difference that we can see is how that
should cannabinoids cannot be coming and
cannabidiol number two and three we're
colluding in the under of attacks
chromatograms but in the derivatives
chromatogram they pretty well separated
the reason why this happens is because
each cannabinoid the based on their
chemical structure have different
numbers of available solution sites and
these leads to higher structural
differences that will of course lead to
further differentiation in the gas
chromatography so this table actually
shows on the other hand how we are going
to we are going to talk and describe the
multiple reaction monitoring results we
call it a database so I have the
database also for the derivatives once
but for the purpose of this presentation
I'm just gonna show one of them because
it's a huge set of numbers and it may or
may not be extremely interested in the
long run but as you can see so we talked
earlier about the first ion that is
formed in the electron ionization in the
electron impact source and that is going
to be in for instance the first column
called the quant ion it's gonna be the
first number on the left of France for
instace hundred and 331st
and 31
and at the end 195 so that is the first
ion that is allowed to pass through the
first quadrupole and reach the second
one then the number on the right of the
equation like 174 and 238 represent
actually the product iron so the ones
that are formed after the fragmentation
with argon and that are passing through
the triple quadrupole and this number
represents the only one out of all the
different fragments that is allowed to
reach the detector so we you can see how
there are three different columns that
describe three different transitions for
each cannabinoid and you in many
experiments only one transition
transition is the is enough to actually
specify and the differentiate among
different molecules but in this case
once we were studying the results with
how the cannabinoids between CBD and CBD
actually share the same transition so we
decided to use even the second
transition to further differentiate
among them and there is a higher
differentiation but we can still see the
same transition for CBD and Delta 9 THC
so this is the reason why we decided to
pass to the third transition so in this
case by using 3 transitions we decrease
the sensitivity but we increase the
specificity for each cannabinoid and
another thing that we started of course
looking at because of all these similar
numbers is that there some of these
fragments must be extremely stable in
the mass pack and even if cannabinoids
do not start from the same molecular
weight so even if they are not isobaric
they may end up forming the same
fragment so we decided to further
investigate and we started speculating
about what could be happening in the
detector and why some of these fragments
may be forming so this is actually still
a work in progress but in here I'm just
gonna show you how for instance the
fragment 231 is formed not only by Delta
9 THC and CBD that are isobaric
cannabinoids but also by Canobie 0 that
is
non isobaric then from there we get
different fragments from CBG but I think
this is an extremely important and
interesting point so for the the
work-in-progress then we're still doing
we decided to compare these transitions
and this fragmentation happening in the
GC to what may be happening in DLC with
different sources so hopefully that will
be done soon as well but yeah as we
mentioned earlier this type of this type
of mode and this type of separation is
really useful for trace analysis because
the limits of detection that we get is
picograms on column that are a way that
are way below what we are actually going
to get in the planter so this method
could be used for potency testing but it
would be a waste of instrumentation in
my opinion and a waste of the waste of
research time so for talking about
potency testing we then decided to use
the instrument that I mentioned earlier
talking about terpenes and couple it to
the GC so GC coupled with vacuum
ultraviolet detector so briefly I'm
gonna introduce these new detector it's
you can see the picture on the right on
the top of the slide and then there is a
diagram in the bottom of how it's
actually built the detector itself is
not extremely big it's pretty much this
longer and this wide so the vacuum
ultraviolet detector is go like that
because it absorb
analyzes each molecule that absorbs
between 120 and 240 nanometer so it
includes even the vacuum ultraviolet
part of the spectrum and as we mentioned
earlier each different molecule is going
to give a unique absorbance spectrum so
even if two isomers are being analyzed
we can easily differentiate between them
and this is why we say that it's
complementary to the mass spec because
as we saw earlier in the mass spec
isobaric components get
Menten but in a similar way while in
here and as you will see earlier later
even delta Eden Delta 9 THC even if
their difference is only the position of
the double bond they have extremely
different absorbance spectra and so they
can be differentiated and my favorite
capability of this instrument is they
can the convolution of colluding
analytes so we will see how it's not so
important to perform and to obtain a
perfect chromatography separation
because the difference in the absorbance
spectra of each analyte can actually be
used in post run to separate at Shuko
loading Peaks so for this reason the GC
coupled with the V V is the ideal for
the analysis of both terpenes and
cannabinoids and you can see in here the
first analysis we performed with under
advertised cannabinoid so just like
before we analyzed 7 of them because
Delta 9 THC a can be analyzed only
facilitated and you on the right there
are the different absorbance spectra so
as you can see how different they are so
you can clearly differentiate between
the different molecules but also because
they all belong to the same class of
come of chemicals you can see how they
pretty much follow a similar pattern
with the one absorbance maximum at
around 180 and one at 210 so by looking
at these image you can already pretty
much understand how these unknown
compounds and fall under the same class
of chemicals while on the Left we have
the chromatographic separation as we saw
earlier with the GCMs cannabidiol and
cannabic Ramin are actually colluding
but in this case it's not a problem
because the de convolving power of the
GC v UV
he is going to take the true absorbance
spectra of the chocolate in peaks and
subtracted to the colluding peak in fact
once two peaks are colluding the
observer
spectrum of the colluding peak is
actually the sum of the two single our
peaks so in post run it's extremely easy
to differentiate among them and you can
see that in the bottom right
chromatograph it's a part of the
chromatography how the quaalude in peak
is actually been separated into CBD and
cbc first quantitation and not only
qualification then we perform the
analysis on the derivatives cannabinoid
as well so already you can see how we
added Delta 9 THC a and house be DN CBC
wants derivatives are actually further
away from each other and most
interestingly on the right side of the
slide you can see how the absorbance
spectra are changed compared to the
knowns to the nozzle elated cannabinoids
and how more different they are between
each other so if on the ones if on the
one hand the GCMs analysis was done and
more suitable for trace analysis this
type of detector and is perfectly
suitable for a faster potency testing
and now for the last part of our
research projects we examine that the
different terpenes that we can find in
cannabis on GC VV well actually not all
of them but we just chose a handful set
of them and first of all I want to
highlight even in the case of terpenes
just like with cannabinoids you can
already pretty much group the terpenes
in two different classes based on their
absorbance spectra so you can see how
similar they are based on having only
one double bond or having two double
bonds or being oxygenated with double
bonds so even if it's not exactly known
the structure of the therapy is by just
having a quick glance at their
absorbance spectrum we can already
identify in what type of class they are
going to fall and even this one is
actually a work in progress so you will
see in here the first chromatographic
separation that we obtain that is 45
minutes
we are actually fastening it to ten
minutes and we are even trying to get
the best extraction technique because
this is actually what is extremely
challenging about terpenes analysis
there is not a validated efficient
extraction method so there are different
extraction methods but none of them has
been reported to be perfectly suitable
for each type of application so you can
see in this type of chromatogram how the
standards of terpenes were separated
among each other and you can see how the
peak at 25 minutes pretty much looks
higher in intensity than the other ones
and this is not because of the higher
concentration of this terpene but it's
because it's the collusion of two
different of two different terpenes come
for and it's a poly go so just like what
we did with cannabidiol and kenabeek
remain in post run we can actually we
can actually differentiate between them
so as we as I mentioned that this
analysis is still a work in progress
we are developing the most or an
efficient extraction method of terpenes
by using headspace analysis and we are
cutting down the analysis GC time to ten
minutes and we hopefully are going to be
validating this method so on but even
once this method has been validated the
road for fully understanding and
characterizing terpenes is really long
because we all know that terpenes are
naturally found in cairo forms and these
different cairo for these enantiomers
they are extremely hard to separate that
you need a special column in GC that
would be cyclodextrins
and they have because they have
identical properties but they they may
have different medical benefits they
have different fragrances they have
different orders so how far the two
different enantiomers of alpha-pinene
may be
extremely different in the properties
among each other and this is why it's
important to actually differentiate and
quantify both enantiomers and not only
alpha-pinene so once I said that I would
like to thank everybody for being here
today and listening to the presentation
and of course I would like to thank
everybody in the Turkish group of where
their support throughout the years I
would like to thank the University of
Texas at Arlington and also image the
scientific instruments res the
corporation and VOB analytics for the
instruments and consumables that were
given to us for this project so thank
you very much for your attention and if
you have any question you can either
type them in now or send the I left in
here my email email addresses so feel
free to send an email any time thank you
very much thank you dr. Louisa for that
informative presentation I'd also like
to thank lab roots for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that this
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through June 28 2019 as a final
reminder our speaker will follow up with
any questions you've submitted via email
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and we will see you next time